[Music]
today i'll show you how to use
object versioning with cloud storage and
some examples of working with versioned
objects
so as you can see i've got a storage
bucket already set up named
tiny homes and i've put a few photos of
my favorite tiny homes in the bucket
so using our console what we want to do
is we want to type in the command
gsutils versioning set on gs
tiny homes this will enable versioning
for the tiny homes bucket
that tells cloud storage to create a new
version of an object each time the live
version of the object is
overwritten or deleted if i want to stop
versioning
all i have to do is write this command
gsutil versioning set off
gs tiny homes if i
ever need to see whether or not
versioning is enabled
it's very easy to figure that out we can
just quickly write this command
called gs versioning get gs
tiny homes and as you can see if we get
enabled this means that versioning is
enabled for this bucket
now let's work with some version objects
here is my tiny homes bucket filled with
tiny home pictures i've uploaded
multiple versions
of tiny home to this bucket only the
most recent version is visible
in the bucket but i can see all the
versions that have existed
with this command
if i want to access any version that's
not the most recent
all i need to do is just to append the
generation number to the object
like this there now you have it
you too can manipulate past or present
versions
of your storage objects
you